-Welcome back, everybody.
We're hanging out with
Keke Palmer!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Keke, I feel like you and I have
a really good connection.
And right now I'd like to play
a game where we can prove it.
It's time for the "Jinx
Challenge." Here we go.
-♪ J-J-J-Jinx ♪
♪ J-J-J-Jinx Challenge ♪
-Alright, now here's how it
works.
We read a category --
I like your dance.
Jinx challenge.
I'm going to read a category
from the card
and then count to three
and we're both going to say
something in that category
at the same time, okay?
-Okay, oh, my gosh.
-If we say the same thing,
it's a jinx, and we want jinxes.
-Yes, okay, great.
-The more jinxes,
that's how we win.
-How many tries we get?
-Do three tries.
-Three tries each.
Okay, here we go.
-Alright, ready?
Let's see what
the first category is.
Okay. Winter clothing.
Winter clothing.
Okay?
-I'm ready.
-One, two, three.
Hat.
-Sweater.
-Okay.
[ Sad tuba ]
Okay.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
-This is it.
-Now, we know this.
-Are you ready for this?
-Are you ready for that?
-Winter clothing.
One, two, three.
-Scarf!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I knew it!
I knew it.
-I really knew it too.
-Oh, my gosh, Jimmy.
This is good. Okay.
-I love it.
Alright, we got a jinx.
-We got this stuff.
-Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
-We love this so much.
-Things in the ocean.
Things -- Things in the ocean?
-Yeah.
Things in the --
-You know what things.
-You know what's in the ocean.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. One, two, three.
Fish.
-Whale.
[ Sad tuba ]
[ Laughter ]
Ow!
-Knew it was going to get tough.
-Okay. It's gonna get --
Alright.
Yeah, 'cause they all
the same down there.
-Uh-huh. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Things in the ocean.
-Okay, okay, okay.
Come on, come on, come on.
-In the ocean?
-[ Stammers ]
-Okay, ready?
-I said whales, you said fish,
what is it?
Here we go. One, two, three.
-Crab.
-Dolphins.
[ Sad tuba ]
[ Laughter ]
No!
-Ah! Things in the ocean.
-Okay. We got one.
This is our last shot.
We know this.
[ Laughter ]
-What thing would be
in the ocean?
-You just did something that
made me go there.
-You know what I'm saying?
-I know what it is.
-Something might be
in the ocean.
-I know what it is.
-One, two, three.
A boat.
-Octopus.
[ Sad tuba ]
[ Laughter ]
You made a leap.
You went to objects.
-I know.
-Dang it.
-I was giving octopus vibes?
-I thought we were giving
tentacles here.
-No, I was doing like a boat.
I was on a boat.
-You was rocking.
-I was rocking.
-You were rocking the boat.
-We got one jinx.
Alright, we got one jinx.
That's good.
Okay, ready for this one?
This category is --
-Here we go.
-Something red.
-Oh, something red.
-Come on.
-Right?
-Oh, yeah.
-Come on.
I'll just put this
in the jinx category.
Something red. One, two, three.
Roses.
-Lipstick.
[ Sad tuba ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Something red.
-Okay. Oh, oh, oh. We know this.
[ Laughter ]
This, something red.
Come on. Come on.
The one thing that we all know.
-It's something red that we know
are red, of course, is one --
No, I'm not feeling it.
[ Laughter ]
Red.
Something red -- it's the
only -- this thing is only red.
-You know it.
[ Laughter ]
I'm ready.
-One, two, three.
Strawberries.
-Stoplight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Sad tuba ]
They don't know what the hell --
-No, because they were like,
"Wait, did they get it?"
-They were like, "Yeah!"
-Stoplight was good.
-I said stoplight,
but you said strawberry.
[ Audience ohs ]
[ Sad tuba ]
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But -- But let's keep thinking
in your area.
You kind of almost --
This is very interesting.
-Oh.
-You know what I'm saying?
-I know. We gonna get it here.
Y'all ready for this?
-Are you ready for this?
One, two, three.
-Stop sign!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God. This is so --
-Stop sign! Oh!
-I mean, I was so close to
bringing up my girl, Diana,
but I was like,
"That's too much."
-I know, we got it, though.
We were there.
We got it.
-Oh, my gosh, I love us.
-I got to calm down.
-We're literally competing
against no one
but we're thrilled.
-I know. We're so excited.
[ Laughter ]
But that's how competitive
we are.
Alright. Here we go.
Aww, baby products.
-Oh! Come on.
-Oh, come on. Come on.
One, two, three.
Diapers.
-Pampers.
Yeah, same. Yeah, we got it.
We got it.
Pampers. That's it.
[ Ding! ]
Pampers. Diapers.
That's it.
Get ready. A lot of diapers.
-I know I'm so ready
for the diaper changing.
Am I though?
-Yes.
No spoilers. You're going to be
ready for everything.
You're going to be so good.
It's so fun.
-I love it.
-The whole experience is so fun.
-I'm so excited just to look
into the eyes.
-Right?
-You know, but don't you think
that sometimes babies
look a little smish
when they first came out?
[ Laughter ]
I'm gonna be like,
"Who's this goblin?"
[ Laughter ]
After a couple of months,
"I recognize you."
-Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
You're me, you're me.
This is the last one here.
This is worth 10,000 points.
-Really?!
I love that.
-Right?
-Invisible points.
A win is a win.
-A win is a win. Here we go.
Game shows.
-Oh!
-One, two, three.
-Password!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's Keke Palmer right there!
Check out her digital network,
KeyTV, and her podcast,
"Baby, This Is Keke Palmer,"
which is available
now on Amazon Music.
Jeff Gordon joins us after
the break. Stick around.